vous venez de suivre l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron on va discuter de ce
qui s'est dit de ce qu'a dit le chef de
l'État intervé par Gilles Bouleau je
suis accompagné de Guillaume Rocket
directeur du film au magazine bonjour
Guillaume bonsoir Vincent merci d'être
avec nous et merci à vous les
internautes d'être nombreux à nous
suivre n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser
vos questions on essaye d'y répondre
comme d'habitude Guillaume déjà une
première question globalement quelle
impression vous a fait cette interview
d'Emmanuel Macron je pense qu'il a voulu
montrer que il était toujours là que il
avait encore des choses à dire aux
Français il m'a semblé que c'était
davantage une posture que un exercice de
communication politique parce que il n'y
a vraiment pas grand chose de marquant à
retenir de cette interview à d'annonce
nouvelle c'est plus un bilan qu'il
défend que des perspectives neuves qui
le qu'il trace je prendrai juste deux
exemples Elisabeth borne aucun
engagement sur la durée de son mandat
c'est normal le président fait ce qu'il
veut mais
vous attendez quand même des messages
éventuels et puis cette baisse d'impôts
le Président nous dit ce sera quand la
trajectoire budgétaire le permettra bon
bah avec ça on n'est pas beaucoup plus
avancé oui alors il a dit avant la fin
du mandat a priori quand même absolument
mais 4 ans quand j'ai le boulot a essayé
de le relancer sur un peu qu'est-ce que
voilà quand est-ce qu'aura lieu cette
baisse d'impôts pareil il a demandé
comment précisément elle a elle allait
s'appliquer il a d'abord été très
catégorique puis un peu plus flou on va
dire oui je pense que il y a il y a
parfois des bonnes raisons de ne pas
répondre aux questions des journalistes
par exemple quand Emmanuel Macron dit je
ne vous dirai pas précisément les
équipements militaires que nous
fournissons à l'Ukraine il a raison
parce que ça pourrait aider les Russes
en revanche il est clair qu'il n'a pas
aujourd'hui de calendrier avec des
éléments précis pour ces baisses
d'impôts sur les classes moyennes qui
nous ont été promises il le dit
d'ailleurs je ne ferai pas le travail du
gouvernement à sa place alors
pourrait-on se dire pourquoi il choisit
de de nous parler de précis à nous
annoncer et je pense vraiment que l'idée
c'est de de d'effacer l'image d'un
président qui ne serait pas au contact
cette image elle s'est forgée pendant la
réforme des retraites quand Emmanuel
Macron refusait de recevoir les
syndicats alors aujourd'hui il ne peut
plus faire des grands débats comme il en
avait organisé après les gilets jaunes
parce que systématiquement il est
accueilli par des des concerts de
casseroles donc qu'est-ce qui fait ben
il vient parler à la télévision j'aime
pas la télévision il vient parler un peu
partout d'ailleurs figurez-vous que
c'est la question qu'on me posait
aujourd'hui sur le site du Figaro la
stratégie d'omniprésence médiatique des
manuel Macron peut-elle être efficace on
laisse d'ailleurs répondre Emmanuel
Macron il est partout en ce moment en
France dans des il se montre énormément
oui alors il a toujours été très actif
mais c'est vrai que on a le sentiment
qu'il y a là une sorte de de montée en
puissance avec des rendez-vous
thématiques tout ça est quand même très
professionnel il faut bien le
reconnaître vous avez vu la semaine
dernière l'annonce de ces 13
d'investissement étrangers cette
se déplacement pour célébrer l'arrivée
d'une gigafactory c'est comme ça qu'on
dit aujourd'hui de construction
de batterie par un fabricant taïwanais
aujourd'hui il reçoit Elon Musk il y a
cette idée que le président est au
travail il n'a jamais arrêté de
travailler Emmanuel Macron a des défauts
comme nous tous mais il a toujours été
extrêmement active une capacité à se
démultiplier entre les dossiers
économiques les dossiers sociaux les
dossiers internationaux simplement il
veut que ça se voit et donc il met en
scène tout cela l'idée c'est aussi de
montrer qu'il n'est pas du tout abattu
par la la contreperformance politique
qui a été cette réforme des retraites
qui majoritairement est toujours refusé
par les Français oui effectivement il
faut passer à autre chose lui essaye en
tout cas de de passer à autre chose via
ce bien là du coup via en faisant
beaucoup de bruit et en montrant qu'il
fait autre chose notamment on utilise
et parce qu'il y a eu aussi aujourd'hui
de nombreux patrons qui étaient là il a
aussi là aussi défendu on va dire son
bilan oui c'est vrai et à juste titre
parce que
la bière instruction la
désindustrialisation de la France pardon
c'était un mouvement de long terme mais
on va dire qu'il s'est enrayé le
problème c'est que ces annonces sont
spectaculaire mais elle n'ont pas encore
un impact concret sur l'activité en
France le grand avantage des usines
Emmanuel Macron l'a rappelé c'est que
vous n'êtes pas obligé de les installer
dans les centres d'affaires vous pouvez
les les localiser sur tout le territoire
à condition d'être proche des
infrastructures en particulier routière
mais il y a eu un le stock des emplois
détruits dans l'industrie est encore
supérieure à celui des créations
d'emplois rien qu'en 5 ans
l'automobile française a détruit 100000
emplois donc quand Emmanuel Macron dit
regardez il y a eu 1000 emplois à
nouveau c'est formidable mais on revient
de très loin et donc je pense que les
Français s'ils n'ont pas de sur le
caractère énergique et engagé d'Emmanuel
Macron quand ils lui font des reproches
tu es plutôt d'être méprisants on y
reviendra peut-être mais c'est plutôt
sur les résultats qu'ils viennent
l'interroger et effectivement Emmanuel
Macron a du mal à dépasser cette cette
séquence de des retraites et d'ailleurs
quand on interroge quand j'ai le boulot
lui dit mais vous aviez dit il y a pas
si longtemps que c'était pas la peine de
repousser l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans
qu'est-ce qui répond il dit oui mais
entre-temps il y a une covid et alors je
vois pas le rapport comme on aurait dit
de mes enfants et puis il y a eu la
guerre en Ukraine so what donc on voit
que là il a quand même du mal à être
cohérent être cohérent à montrer
sa cohérence sur le sur le sujet
l'interview a commencé d'abord par le de
l'international zzinsky qui était en
visite hier à Paris avec une question
assez précise qui a été
est-ce qu'on va lui fournir des avions
alors il répond il répond pas tout de
suite il répond
ne fournissons pas d'armes qui
permettrait à l'Ukraine d'aller frapper
en Russie c'est un peu particulier comme
réponse parce que on a par exemple livré
des canons César quand une portée de
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres donc on
peut imaginer les Ukrainiens les
poussant jusqu'à la jusqu'à la frontière
russe dans dans les zones de leur pays
qui sont pas
occupés donc on va dire qu'il y a une
porte entrouverte sur la livraison
d'avion puisque Emmanuel Macron dit on a
commencé la formation de pilote alors la
vérité c'est que c'était un secret de
polichinelle puisque depuis février
dernier le ministère de la défense
reconnaît la formation de de personnel
aéronautique ukrainien de mémoire
c'était un Mont-de-Marsan et à Nancy
sauf disait le ministère que c'était pas
les pilotes comme si on formait des
techniciens par exemple travaillant sur
les mirages sans former les pilotes ça
apparaît assez peu cohérent mais
Emmanuel Macron ne peut pas faire ce
genre d'annonce tout seul les les avions
c'est une stratégie
occidentale une stratégie hôtelienne et
donc il veut montrer sa bonne volonté
mais il va doucement là je pense que
pour le coup le en même temps se
justifie parce que on est sur une ligne
de crête quand il dit et qu'il répète
nous ne sommes pas en guerre avec la
Russie il a raison les Français sont
bien sûr favorables à ce que nous
aidions l'Ukraine pays démocratique
agressé mais en même temps les Français
redoutent une un embrasement de l'Europe
et une guerre plus globale et pour ça il
faut être prudent et là Emmanuel Macron
a raison de l'être humain sur ces sur
ces déclarations vous le savez liberté
ce qui était à Paris hier il y a eu pas
mal on a beaucoup parlé de d'économies
effectivement là où on parlait tout à
l'heure de des investissements en France
mais on a aussi beaucoup parlé de la
classe moyenne de de de ces réductions
d'impôts on lui a demandé est-ce qu'on
peut augmenter les salaires est-ce que
vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour
augmenter les salaires oui et là encore
Emmanuel Macron est cohérent parce qu'il
dit que tu sais pas moi qui décidait la
politique des salaires ce sont les
entreprises il tient sur tous ces sujets
économique un discours on va dire qui
est celui de la droite raisonnable
consistant à dire bah non je vais pas
demander à je ne vais pas forcer la main
de totale par exemple pour pouvoir
distribuer davantage de bénéfices il
répète ce qui est vrai que il a mis en
place des dispositifs notamment de
défiscalisation pour les primes mais
qu'ensuite c'est ce secteur privé de
s'organiser et là encore je trouve que
c'est assez bienvenu de la même façon
quand il dit les grèves quelle grève
sous-entendu il y a que les administes
les services publics toujours les mêmes
RATP SNCF SUV maregard pour les autres
mais le pays le pays qui travaille le
pays du privé lui il s'est pas mis en
grève et ça aussi c'est vrai et là on
peut dire qu'il est droit dans ses
bottes il a d'ailleurs dit les
industriels ils ont pas vraiment vu
qu'il y avait une grève en France
presque il a ajouté ça à j'ai le boulot
de façon assez assez moqueuse
d'ailleurs parce que vous en parlez tout
à l'heure de de de sa ligne il s'est pas
privé au moment de parler de la forme de
retraite une nouvelle attaque contre les
oui parce que il dit et là encore il a
raison que les républicains n'ont a été
cohérents puisqu'une partie d'entre eux
ont refusé de voter cette réforme alors
même qu'elle était dans le programme
présidentiel de Valérie Pécresse et
c'est parce que ces voix des
républicains ont manqué à l'appel que le
gouvernement a été obligé de faire
usage de l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution avec donc cette cette prise
de responsabilité de cette mise en
responsabilité du gouvernement et tout
ça c'est vrai mais le problème c'est que
rien que tout ça n'est nouveau ce sont
des arguments qu'on a déjà entendu dix
fois et c'est là qu'on sent qu'en fait
je pense que le chef de l'État se dit il
faut que j'occupe le terrain pour
montrer que j'ai peur de personne et que
je suis toujours là mais encore une fois
sur le fond il y a pas grand chose de
nouveau à annoncer et je me demande du
coup si vraiment c'est une démarche très
efficace moi je pense plutôt qu'il y a
une forme de lassitude je pense que
Emmanuel Macron a tendance à trop parler
et que
lui s'imagine que ça sa parole est
performative comme disent les
psychologues c'est à dire que le simple
fait de dire aujourd'hui il fait beau
fait qu'il fait beau et ben en fait non
et je pense que le dans une certaine
mesure la magie c'est de 2017 avec
l'énergie de cet homme cette volonté son
côté innovant tout ça ça n'agit plus
aujourd'hui même même si le multiplie
les interventions publiques oui qui me
disent les interventions publiques
est-ce que c'est encore aussi important
qu'avant une interview d'Emmanuel Macron
à la télévision bon ça on le saura
demain oui on verra les audiences mais
je non je ne le pense pas je le pense
pas parce qu'il en a il en a il en a
déjà fait
pas mal ces derniers temps je pense par
exemple à la le l'entretien lors des 13
heures de du de TF1 et de et de France 2
et encore une fois il n'intervient que
pour justifier ces décisions jamais pour
annoncer des ruptures ou des changements
de cap alors encore une fois ça
l'avantage de la cohérence je suis pas
en train de lui reprocher simplement je
m'interroge du coup sur l'efficacité de
cette communication c'est
malheureusement un travers assez
classique des gens très intelligents
c'est que quand ils se retrouvent face à
un mur
ils ne peuvent pas admettre que
peut-être ils n'ont pas suivi le bon
chemin ils se disent mais non c'est
parce que j'ai pas expliqué et donc avec
de la pédagogie ça va s'arranger et en
fait non les Français ils ont tout à
fait compris qu'on voulait les faire
bosser davantage à mon avis
et ils ont pas envie à mon avis on peut
pas faire autrement donc Emmanuel Macron
a raison de pas lâcher là-dessus mais il
peut pas demander aux Français de dire
ah bah finalement on n'avait pas compris
dedans ah bah tiens c'est vrai on savait
pas que les gens vivaient de plus en
plus longtemps tiens on savait pas
qu'avec moins en moins d'enfants en
France ah c'est vrai que ce serait
dommage de de faire payer davantage de
cotisations parce que déjà on en a
beaucoup bon tous ces arguments ils ont
déjà entendu mille fois je pense que ce
n'est pas de son niveau effectivement
d'ailleurs j'ai le boulot lui a dit au
bout d'un moment on en parle d'ailleurs
de au début de cette émission il lui a
repris son tombé présent et Emmanuel
Macron a répondu non les Français ils
disent pas ça il a cité beaucoup de
choses qui pour ressembler à des
qualités en disant un peu comme s'il
disait ah non mais moi je suis
perfectionniste exactement mon défaut
exactement exactement
ça trop travailler
je pense que Emmanuel Macron est sincère
vous savez rien n'est plus difficile que
de voir ses propres défauts et au fond
de lui-même il n'est pas méprisant tous
les gens qui travaillent avec lui disent
que il est extraordinairement investi
dans ce dans ce job de président quand
vous voyez ce que l'emploi du temps
d'Emmanuel Macron
par comparaison par exemple avec celui
d'un Jacques Chirac ou encore plus d'un
François Mitterrand veut dire il est il
est pas du tout désinvolte mais
simplement ça ne ça ne passe pas parce
que
les gens ont construit cette réalité
Emmanuel Macron a raison quand il dit
que l'opposition les réseaux sociaux ont
fabriqué cette image et parfois il
arrive et ça c'est le cas de notre
société postm ou ce n'est plus la
réalité qui compte c'est la
représentation médiatique qui en est
faite et malheureusement cette
représentation c'est celle-là
effectivement alors dans les
commentaires LR pour 2027 et Requiem
Ford n'ont pas été très convaincus en
tout cas pas Emmanuel Macron dernière
petite question sur Elisabeth borne son
sort a été évoqué on sait qu'elle est en
sursis on va dire jusqu'au jusqu'au 14
juillet la date du plan des 100 jours
[Musique]
aurait fallu finalement ce serait
d'aller il faudra prémuner ce qui change
complètement et donc d'aller chercher
d'un côté sur ma droite mais est-ce
qu'il le peut vraiment alors il pourrait
l'essayer même si ça n'a pas été simple
on l'a bien vu avec la réforme des
retraites on y faisait allusion à
l'instant les républicains ont été en
tout cas pour une partie d'entre eux
réticent à s'engager sur une réforme qui
pourtant on faisait partie de leur
programme je pense que il y a pas de
solution pourquoi parce que si Emmanuel
Macron part à droite il va perdre la
gauche de son de son de sa majorité or
il y a un nombre substantiel de députés
Renaissance qui sont
issus du Parti socialiste et donc en
fait
on est dans une espèce de de
d'hésitation permanente l'exemple le
plus caricatural c'est la loi sur
l'immigration qui a été annoncée puis
reporté je crois qu'on en est à 6 fois
je sais même plus quel est le dernier
épisode si aux dernières nouvelles on va
on va on va y avoir droit à cette loi ce
sera en septembre en septembre jusqu'à
la prochaine interview on dira que
finalement il faut prendre le temps de
la négociation donc qu'est-ce que fait
Emmanuel Macron il essaie de gagner du
temps
on voit bien la fragilité de ce
dispositif la vérité c'est que comme il
n'a pas de majorité solide à l'Assemblée
et bien il est entravé ça correspond pas
à son tempérament énergique et douce
cette image d'un président de la
République qui a l'impression que qu'on
ne comprend pas que les Français ne sont
pas à la hauteur de ces espérances mais
ce sont les Français qui ont choisi ils
ont choisi de le réélire mais ils ont
choisi de ne pas lui donner de majorité
claire et évidemment c'est compliqué
merci beaucoup Guillaume Rocket d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous les entotes
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre je
vous renvoie vers cet article vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site du Figaro
Ukraine baisse d'un pot inflation ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'interview
télévisée d'Emmanuel Macron vous pouvez
bien sûr retrouver ce live en replay
pour ceux qui ont raté le début merci
une nouvelle fois bien moquette et je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouveaux live
sur Figaro live